[Music]
in the cold russian winter of 1959
nine students set out on a cross-country
skiing trip in the ural mountains
their bodies were later found in
puzzling circumstances
they tend to have been cut from the
inside
as if they needed to get out of there
the injuries
of the victim so rib and skull fractures
were unusual
there are dozens of theories of what
happened the night they died
things like alien abduction that they
were attacked by
yetis it's this huge mystery that's
obsessed
russia for decades now researchers are
looking at the science of snow to
explain the puzzle
i was really convinced that a small
avalanche could have led to the incident
that night
but after 60 years could new data
really lay to rest the mystery of the
diatlov pass
there's a great reluctance to accept
that they could have been finished off
by something as banal as
a few tons of snow
at the end of january in 1959
seven young men and two young women set
off on a hiking expedition
journalist lucy ash started reporting on
this story in 2019
and traveled to russia to follow the
expedition's route
it's a very beautiful terrain but very
cold and very
unforgiving and they were all quite
experienced at this
kind of trip but this time the students
never returned
a search party was sent out and two
weeks after they were due to return
their tent was found a man called
mikhail sharavin
who i interviewed who's now in his 80s
he saw a tent pole sticking up out of
the snow
their boots were neatly stacked in one
corner there were the remains of a meal
that they seemed to have been
eating and the tent was cut from the
inside
which seemed very strange to them it
wasn't until
the next day that they found the first
of the bodies
it took months for all nine bodies to be
recovered
the students seemed to have left their
tent in a hurry without getting fully
dressed
despite the below freezing temperatures
it was hypothermia that ultimately
killed most of the victims
but some of the bodies showed unexpected
injuries
they were similar to the kinds of
injuries that you would have if you're
involved
in a car accident so a huge amount of
force
against the chest and these were
extraordinarily puzzling for the
investigators they couldn't understand
why the case was swiftly closed but
speculation ran wild it spawned a huge
number of conspiracy theories
i think something like 75 in all
including things like
alien abduction that they were attacked
by
yetis in 2019 60 years on
the russian authorities announced that
they were reopening the investigation
to put an end to the conspiracy theories
once and for all
that's when avalanche expert joanne gome
first heard about the case
some journalists wanted to get my expert
opinion about what happened that night
and especially about
the plausibility of a slab of lunch a
slab avalanche occurs when a dense
slab of snow breaks away from a layer of
weaker snow underneath
when the group cut into the slope to
pitch their tent this could have removed
some of the support for the snow slab
above them
based on my experience not only as a
snow scientist
but also as a snow enthusiast i was
really convinced that a small avalanche
above the tent could have led to the
incident that night the
russian investigation came to the same
conclusion
in 2020 it announced an avalanche as the
main cause of the tragedy
but a lot of the evidence didn't seem to
match and many people were skeptical of
the official line
none of the relatives i spoke to were
very convinced by the avalanche theory
they felt that the slope was too
shallow for an avalanche and they also
felt that
the hikers were too experienced to put
themselves in the path of an avalanche
joanne decided that more research was
needed to explain the evidence
i decided to go deeper from a scientific
point of view
and i teamed up with alexander puzerin
from eth zurich
to do some research based on what we
read we realized that there was
four main counter arguments against the
avalanche hypothesis
so first the slope angle was uh rather
mild so below 30 degrees the second
thing is that there was a delay between
the moment the group made the cut in the
slope and
a potential avalanche then the third
thing
is that the injuries of the victim so
rib
and skull fractures were not typical of
avalanche victims
and finally when the rescue team arrived
26 days
after the incident there was no sign of
an avalanche
joanne and his colleague alexander set
out to investigate each of these four
arguments in turn
so first concerning slope angle there is
a general rule
uh that an avalanche needs a slope angle
of 30 degrees
to release so it's basically when you
have two books like this
you tilt them and at some point they
will slide but in practice this angle
depends on the snow type based on the
investigation reports
we noticed that at the base of the
snowpack there was a very weak
snow layer made of what we call depth
[ __ ]
and this depth sore layer has a highly
angular structure and they have a very
poor
cohesion you see it doesn't stick
together
other types of snow for example here
makes aggregates it sticks together
joanne's research suggests that the
presence of this weak layer
could allow an avalanche to occur on a
slope shallower than 30 degrees
this brings us on to the second argument
against an avalanche
why was there a delay between the group
cutting into the slope
and the supposed avalanche in the middle
of the night several hours later
joanne has modeled the shape of the
mountain and the speed of the winds that
night
these models show that snow being blown
down the mountain
could have gathered above the campsite
so this wind transported snow
right above the tent and this led to
progressive
snow accumulation until the
load became critical at that time
the avalanche released despite appearing
to be a safe camping spot
the combination of a hidden weak layer
of snow the shape of the slope
and the fast winds could have been
enough to cause a catastrophe
but what about the next counter-argument
avalanche victims don't usually show the
kind of injuries found on some members
of the diatlov group
so it didn't seem to match however in
the case of the jet loft incident
at the moment of a potential avalanche
they were sleeping
and so they were lying on the tenth
floor which has been made more rigid
by putting skis below and so when
you have a rigid obstacle like that
behind your back
and you are impacted by snow block this
is very different
to a classical avalanche joanne
simulations show that the types of
fractures seen
could have been caused by falling snow
even with such
a small slab avalanche above it and this
can release
some very hard blocks of size close to
one meter and a block of one meter cubic
has a weight close to 400 kilos and so
if you take
such a block on your chest you can
imagine that this can cause serious
injuries
an avalanche would usually leave clear
signs
but modeling the local topology joanne
and alexander believed that the small
amount of moving snow
could have just filled in the hole cut
by the hikers and left no sign
by the time the search team arrived 26
days later
for joanne and alexander the new data
shows that an avalanche is
plausible but their new paper doesn't
attempt to explain everything
for example radiation was found on some
pieces of clothing
there were missing eyeballs and a tongue
on some of the bodies
and no one knows what happened after the
nine people left the tent that night
the thing about this story is that it's
like a jigsaw
and no matter how many explanations are
offered up
quite often there's another detail that
seems to contradict
personally we do not believe that the
mystery can never be solved because
no one survived to tell the story but
what we did in our paper is to show the
plausibility
of the avalanche hypothesis based on
solid physical and experimental
evidence over the decades the mystery of
the diatlov pass has gained almost
mythical status and for many people
there will always remain unanswered
questions
there's a great reluctance to accept
that these nine
young people could have met their ends
in such a banal way it's like people
cling onto this idea that there was
something otherworldly unearthly about
it
some other overarching cause of this
[Music]
catastrophe
you